では よろしくお願いします
では 今日の話に入ります
えーと 菩薩の下積み大作戦ということで
まあ経験を生かすブッダの智慧
まあ一応あのタイトルをつける場合はね
この副題は本当のタイトルなんです
まあどんな場合でも 本の場合でもどちらでも
副題っていうのは中身を説明するもので
あの大きなタイトルはただの餌です
そういうことで 今日はこの経験を生かすというテーマで
ブッダの世界をね お釈迦様の世界をね
ちょこっと紹介したいと思います
で 例えば我々人間が何かする前に計画を立てるんですね
それから会議もするんですね
それから考えてみることもしますね
それから他人の意見を聞いたり
アドバイスを受けたりもします
で 欲しいやりたいだけの感情で何も考えないことにする場合もあります
何も考えずやってしまう場合もあります
そういうことで５つにしたんです
まあ別にいろいろ数字がありますけど
どうも迷信的にこの５つとか８とか10でなければ気が済まないので
まあ５つにしたんです
そういうわけで あと一行残っていたんですけど
そこで６番目は書かなかったんです
そこで計画を立てるということはどういうことかと
これは必要なものですね
まあ別にいらんというはずはないんですからね
しかし 冷静さというのはね
冷静であるかね それがありますかと
計画を立てると 本当に冷静に落ち着いて我々は計画を立てているのかということは大きな問題なんですね
まあ本当のところ 計画を立てるということは
一応段取りを綺麗に整理整頓させるということですから
計画を立てずやるよりは
どちらかというと計画を立ててやった方がいいんです
計画を立てるのは今なのです
仏教的に見るとこれが大きな問題なんですね
今計画立てるんですよ
この今ということをよく大事に考えてください
実行は将来ですよ 実行するのは将来なんですよ
今っていうのは 今の時間で
今の空間の中のデータで計画を立てるんです
実行するのは将来なんですよ
実行するときは計画を立てた時の状況ではありません
これは必ずあるんです
計画は部屋の中で暖房をつけて
まあおせんべい食べながら立てるかもしれませんだけど
実行は別な日にちで別なところでやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからそこで環境が違うんですね
将来起こり得るものを推測できません
人間には将来こうなるでしょうということは想像できません
推測できません だから計画っていうのはいつでもうまくいかないんです
ですから 計画は簡単に成功しないんです
立てなくちゃいけないんだけど
計画を立てたんだからといって
そう簡単には いくものじゃないんです
そこは仏教徒はよく考えるものなんですよ
計画はすごい精密に立てますけど
いつでもその通りにいかない可能性もありますよと
よく知っているんです
2番目 会議するっていうこと
まあ仕事はいくつかの分野に分けるものなら
専門家と会議必要があります
我々は何かやりたいことがいろんな分野のに分けて
セクションごとにやらなくちゃいけないことだったら
そのその人の専門家の意見を聞いて合わせて
あなたの仕事は何日間かかるのか
例えば段取りもありますから
ある仕事を先にやるとか
ある仕事を後でやるとかね
ある仕事にはかなり前から準備必要とか
そういう風ないろんな仕事次第にいろいろありますので
会議する必要もあります
ないとは言えないんです
しかし 同類の人々を集めて好き勝手に話すと
何の結論にも至れなくなるんです
しかし 世の中である会議っていうのは
ただ同じ分野の同じ考えの人々を集めて
キャーキャーキャーキャーキャー喋ってるだけで
ただもう時間の無駄で何の結論にも至らなくなっちゃいます
だから同じ分野の人が喋ると
どうしてもそれはあるものなんですよ
結論に達しなくなっちゃうんです
皆様に経験あるかもしれません
そういう何か重大な会議とかやっている場合は
同じ専門家が集まるんですよ
ろくな結果にならないんです
提案者のやる気はなくなってしまうこともあります
その場合は全く違う方向へ進むことも
結局はダメになることもあり得るんですよ
何か計画を立てて こういうことをしましょうかと会議をやっていると
会議の結果 まるっきり別な方向へ行ってしまうこともあるし
いえ これはできません
ダメです ダメだよというふうなことにもなりますよ
だから会議といったっても
必ずいいということはないんですね
時間のロスになる会議は結構多いんですよ
よくただ喋るだけ 時々政府とかそういう大きな組織で
そういう審査会なんとかやると
参加するたびにすごいお金くれるんですよ
また ものすごいごちそうあれ注文して
毎回パーティーやったりとかね
だからとにかく日にち延ばすんです
延ばして  2年  3年経ってから結論なく据え置きで終わっちゃうんです
特に日本の 我々日本に来てるんだから
日本のことをよくご存知でしょうし
もうほんの少々のことでも
政府がで変えようと思っちゃうと
何年も経ちますけど 結局はもう据え置きでも変えられなくない
変えられないんですよ
最近ね 教育の問題が出てきて
もう今音沙汰も何もないんです
忘れちゃったんです いじめの問題とかね
小学生 中学生はなんで自殺するのかとか
キャーキャーと喋って
よく金儲けて それで終わり
です だから無駄な会議なんですよ
真剣じゃないんですよ
何か何か改良しなくちゃという進歩的じゃないんです
腰が重くて わが身を守るだけ
自分に利益あれば それは何にもしませんよという感じで
まあだから無駄なんですね
本当に 特に政府っていうものは
ものすごく早くテキパキと動く人々がやらないとうまくいかないんです
それで 3番目 考えてみるということ
まあ言いますけど 仏教では会議はありません
ありますけど 会議ということでもないんですよね
何か提案する場合は まあ提案する人は
それはそれなりにしっかりした提案をするんです
それでは聞いている人々にとっては
ただ賛成か反対だけで話は終了します
反対もそう簡単には 仏教の世界では
簡単には言えませんですよ
反対する人はそれなりのしっかりしたデータやら論理やら出さないと
だからその なんでそれ成り立つかというと
一人一人がすごい真剣ということなんです
いい加減じゃないんです
しかし 考え方には癖があります
今考えることなんですけどね
まあそれは必要なものですよ
考えなきゃ何もならないんだからね
しかし 考えて何かするといっても
考え方に癖があるんですよ
この我々 人格とか何とかいう個人差っていうのは
その人の思考パターンなんですね
だから誰にでも思考に癖がついているんですよ
癖がついている思考で何を考えて結論を出しても
そちらにもその偏見が入り込むんですよ
それからいくらでも考えられます
思考っていうのはかなり危ないもので
この停止しないでずっと続いてしまいますよ
そういうわけで 考える時のブッダのガイドラインがありますよ
ただ単にもう当てもなく考えてはいけません
これで病気になります
生きるエネルギーっていうのはもう頭
心ですからね それが無駄な思考に浪費しちゃうと
もう智慧が現れなくなります
考えることでどうしても智慧がなくなっちゃいますよ
智慧っていうのは 瞬時に正しい答えがひらめくことなんです
瞬間にひらめくんです
ひらめいたものについて考えて
こういうことだよというのは簡単で
その場合は思考がそんな延々と伸びません
それで正しく仏教的に考えると
メリット デメリット 方法
それから周りとの関わりという 4つで考えるならば具体的なんです
4つですね で 何かやろうとすると
メリットを考えてみる
デメリットを考えてみる
それからそのやりたい方法はいわゆる実効的ですかとかね
どういうふうにやればよろしいかとかね
その 3番目 それから 4番目
実行したっても この環境の中で我々は生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
人間と社会と環境がありますね
そこで環境にどんな関わりあるの？環境に悪い影響でしょうか
環境に良い影響でしょうか
周りは賛成するか反対するか
それは大事なことなんですよ
子供たちは自分でいろんなことをやりたいと言い出したっても
親が反対すればやるでしょうに
だから子供はいい加減バカなことを考える前に
親の態度も自分の思考の中に入れなくちゃいけないんです
やりたいからやっちゃっても
まあいくらでも考える場合は
必ずそれは環境の関わりも考えなくちゃいけない
その 4つのところで考えるならば
思考は無限にということはないんです
しかし 人間には思考の管理できません
問題はそんなことは人間丸っきり気にしないに思考の管理はないんです
どこまででも考えるか
諦めるかですよ あるいはどこまでも無限のループで考えるか
もう嫌だ もうやめたというふうにやめるか
そういうことはよく社会で見られます
何もしないでやめちゃう
学校をやめちゃうとかね
仕事を辞めたとか はい
次に行きます  4番目 他人の意見を聞く
まあまあ 要は短くしたんですけど
聞いたり アドバイスを受けるというね
とても良いこととして見えるんでしょ？人の意見を聞く
アドバイスを聞くっていうことは
それはもうどうしても必要なんです
アドバイスの質は 他人の責任感
相手に対する親切さなどに左右されます
人はアドバイスしますけど
アドバイスの質があるんですよ
それがアドバイスする人の責任感に左右されます
例えば 若い人が母親にアドバイス聞くと
母親はすごい子供に対しては真剣ですね
じゃあ友達から聞いてみると
友達は別にその人の将来幸福のためにそんな真剣じゃないんです
ですから 友達にも仲間に聞くアドバイスと母親に聞くアドバイスの質が違うんです
それで 他人でも親切な人だったらいつでもすごく親切に丁寧にアドバイスをする
自分の考えをなくして相手の意見に乗らなくてはならないこともあるんです
人のアドバイスを聞いてやり過ぎになっちゃうと
結局はもともと自分考えたことは何でしょうかとも忘れちゃって
相手が言うことに乗せてしまうこともあります
だから結局アドバイスを聞くということの危険性は
マインドコントロールされて操られる可能性もあります
だからやたらにアドバイス聞くんじゃない
そのところでも 我々は気をつけるべきポイントっていうのはいくつでもたくさんあります
特にこの頭の悪い人に限って
喋る時はすごい大胆なんですね
声がでかい 全部結論付けて喋るんです
その場合は 聞いた人はすぐそちらに乗せられてしまいます
で 理性的に 例えば 学校の先生にアドバイス聞いたら
子供たちすごく嫌になっちゃう
あの先生何も言ってくれないんだと
先生は真剣なんです 君
将来こういうことをやりなさいとは言いません
結論出して 能力は知ってますよ
何者かと 親よりも そこは親切ですから
君の人生だから君で考えてくださいとかね
何考えているの？とか
そういうことをやりたい
やりたいのかとかね なんでそういうことに決めたんでしょうかとか
そういう風にこのもう相手の立場を守ってあげて
このしっかり道を自然にできるようにするばするんですけど
もう困って困り果てている子は
いい この学校をやめて
あの学校に進学しなさいと言ってほしいんですね
それで言ったらどうなること？と言ったらまた反対する
でもあの学校もいいんじゃないんでしょうかと
ですから この無知な人にアドバイス聞いたら何のことない
いえ まああちら あんたはこれにします
しなさいと これダメ ダメ
やめなさいよ 何やってるのかと
いきなりそうやってもうすごい態度で言うんです
そうすると相手がもう自然にそれに乗ってしまうんですね
ですから アドバイスを受けるということはいいことですが
仏教の世界ではそれでも気をつけるということがあるんです
ダメになる目的でいうアドバイスもありますね
それから知恵 理性があり
慈しみの人のアドバイスのみ有効ですということで
まあガーッと言ってハトにいるというのは
その風にやってますか？って意味なんです
これが正しい道なんですけど
それでアドバイスを受けたところでダメなアドバイスをする
そういう人間も平気でいるんです
ものすごいいるんです
だから気をつけなくちゃいけない
では 誰からアドバイスを受けるべきかというと
理性があって 知恵があって
物事をよく知っていて
経験もあって それから慈しみがある
相手に対して嫉妬も憎しみも怒りも何もなく
幸福であってほしいと成功してほしいという慈しみもある
そこで正しいアドバイスは言ってくれます
だからアドバイスを受ける場合は
ブッダ言うのはいつでも知恵のある人のアドバイスのみ聞きなさいよと
みんなのアドバイスを聞くということは認めていないんです
５番目 欲しいやりたいだけの原因ですね
気持ちは良いものであるならば活発
また間違ってます 活発的で諦め
諦めない精神で問題にならないんですね
まあ欲しいやりたいと思っても悪くはないんですよ
この欲しいやりたいということが良いことであれば
それは大丈夫です しかし
欲と怒りだけなら何の意味もありません
欲しいと思ったのは欲だけで
あるいは怒りで それだったら何の意味もありませんね
時々誰かに勝ちたくて
あれこれやりたくなったりする場合もありますね
それは意味がないんです
まあ例えば まあドイツ語を習いたいんだと
なぜか いえ どうしても欲しい
好きやと それは別に悪くないんです
だからドイツに留学して
ペラペラ喋れるようになりたいと
いうならば あのね あんた
何のためにそんなことを考えること全然ない
ただのただ好きだけ ただ好きだけでも
それは悪いことじゃないんです
そんなに好きだったら
じゃあ勝手にやりなさいとやらせればいいんです
だから欲しいだけで あの
でもやる やりたがってることは悪いものでなければね
それ結構行動的なんで
その場合は 本人やりたがってるんだから
あまり苦労気にしないで頑張るんですね
また 未熟な人は自分に対して良いと感情的になっても
必ず良い結果になるとは限りません
それで人間というのは未熟で
特に子供たちやらね まあ若者っていうのはもう未熟に決まってるでしょうね
それでものすごく厳しく決めるんですね
やりたいことは将来的に
でもそれでは将来うまくいくかどうかっていうことはそう限ってないんですからね
それでこういう欲しいだけの人っていうのは
意見は聞かないんですね
人の話は聞き聞きません
耳に入りません 親の話とかは
そういうので頑固で無知になってしまうこともあります
そういうポイントはいくつかあります
まあはい それでまあ 一つのセクションが終わりました